Daenerys Targaryen is known by many
titles and on the latest episode of Game
of Thrones she gains another one a name
she insisted she would never take on as
long as she could help it here's how the
twist went down and what it all means
Daenerys admits she has only known fear
in Westeros not the love that her nephew
boyfriend and potentially rival claimant
to the Iron Throne Jon Snow has come to
receive this realization combined with
her newfound knowledge that her master
of whisperers Varys committed treason
against her and shifting his loyalty to
John Plus the recent death of her
trusted advisor Masson day pushes
Daenerys past her breaking point the
mother of dragons dives headfirst into
the madness that her father the
so-called Mad King suffered when he sat
on the Iron Throne omits Robert's
rebellion in episode 5 Dany became the
mad Queen destroying King's Landing and
killing thousands of innocent men women
and children on her mission to unseat
Cersei Lannister and take the Iron
Throne herself the iron boom
perhaps you should try wanting something
else
Dany time and again has stated that
she's not a carbon copy of her father
and she wouldn't make the same mistakes
he did I am NOT here to be queen of the
ashes but that's exactly what wound up
happening during this latest episode in
a moment many viewers felt was a wild
twist however in the eyes of Game of
Thrones showrunners Daenerys going mad
wasn't exactly a big shock David Benioff
and Dan Weiss explained during the shows
inside the episode featurettes that
Thrones had long for shadow Dany
spiraling into instability and that
there are plenty of clues sprinkled
throughout past seasons that signaled
this dark turn would happen eventually
one such clue is the death of Daenerys
brother Viserys back in season one Danny
didn't second-guess her decision to have
called Drogo pour molten gold over
Viserys head and refused to look away
when the deed was carried out wanting to
watch him suffer through the pain
he is no TRACON
if I cannot kill that dragon Daenerys
has a history of killing or ordering
others to kill on her behalf and
exhibiting no signs of hesitancy or
remorse she burnt a witch alive and
almost relished in her cries she
sentenced people to die in a vault den
didn't think twice Daenerys also burnt a
slave-owner
alive and was thrilled to do it she gave
a chilling speech about how she deserved
to rule just before she burnt a horde of
Dothraki warlords to death and who could
forget her ruthless flaming of Samwell
Tarly 'he's brother and father plus her
execution of varus that came at the top
of this very episode the season has
shown time and time again that Daenerys
isn't afraid of doling out death
sentences and she's been pretty clear
about her intentions from the start we
will take back what was stolen from me
and destroy and those who wronged me we
will lay waste to armies and burn cities
to the ground but that attitude
contrasts harshly with the other side of
her personality the side that frees
wrongfully enslaved people liberate
cities and promises to break the wheel
of oppression instead of simply taking
her own turn as the person in charge
Dany turning into the person she said
she would never become the woman who
strikes fear in the hearts of the
Westeros II people the queen of the
ashes the spitting image of her father
was shocking to behold even if there
were some breadcrumbs leading up to the
snapping point Dan wisest said he
doesn't feel that Daenerys always
intended to burn King's Landing and its
citizens to a crisp though there was a
lot of buildup that would show cause for
her doing so rather Weiss noted that
Dany decided to take that course of
action the moment she arrived in the
capital city it's in that moment on the
walls of King's Landing where she's
looking at that symbol of everything
that was taken from her when she makes
the decision to make this personal
Benioff added that Daenerys may never
have become the Mad Queen if her journey
to the iron throne had played out
differently circumstances have been
different I don't think the side of Dany
ever would have come out if Cersei
hadn't betrayed her if Sir she hadn't
executed me someday if John hadn't told
her the truth
unfortunately this side of Daenerys
Targaryen did come out and it will
probably be her
doing it's tough to imagine the people
of Westeros rallying behind Daenerys
after she needlessly murdered thousands
of people via dragon fire and decimated
the capital now that she's gone full Mad
Queen Dany likely can't go back to the
person she used to be her dream to sit
on the Iron Throne may never come true
despite her greatest enemy Cersei dying
in the chaos of the siege and John
constantly saying he will always support
Danny it will be an intense fight to the
finish during the final episode of Game
of Thrones as Daenerys actors Emilia
Clarke told The Hollywood Reporter it's
the car crash of every emotion you can
possibly imagine it's like a nuclear
bomb check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about Game of Thrones they're coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]